i am running out of patience
with this app hey everyone i'm abby
sharp welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by buildbar
and i am back with another tick tock
review
since there is apparently no shortage of
brutal wellness advice on that dumpster
fire
of an app i thought the content on tick
tock was problematic
enough last time i reviewed some videos
but i was
not prepared to swipe through this
volume
of pro ed content when i went for
another go
but first a quick note about my sponsor
built bar if you are a regular abby's
kitchen
viewer here you've probably been
watching me work through this box
of build bars every single week and i'm
not usually a fan of most protein bars
because
i think they kind of taste like chalk
but these
legit taste like a chocolate bar filled
with a
nuggety marshmallow they're so so good
so today i'm going back to my favorite
because i think i've tried them all now
the cookies and cream
[Music]
gonna have cookies and cream oh
[Music]
that is good yeah i probably have chalk
in my teeth but i don't care because
it's that good
this has got 17 grams of protein so it's
great if you're trying to bump
up the protein in a meal or a snack
and if i was using this as a post
workout snack
i probably would want to pair this with
like a piece of fruit or
toast for muscle repair since it is a
lower sugar snack and bar
but if you want to try them out i'm
going to leave my link below
for you to get 20 off of your order
anyway you guys know the drill you can
pause my screen to see my disclaimer
and also a reminder for those struggling
with disordered eating
you may feel more comfortable sitting
this one out it's definitely
gonna be rough so today we're gonna look
at three
popular what i in a days to lose weight
that i came across
on the tick tock app and again like i
said for my ed warriors
huge tickers in all of these so please
feel free to skip to the time stamp at
the very end
if you just want to hear my parting
thoughts anyway
first up exhibit a
oh my gosh this has been a saga
so i recorded this a while ago and then
i went to go get the clip
and it was deleted which was actually a
really good thing
because it was triggering as it
basically featured this young
tic talker eating just over 800 calories
part of which was a protein bar which
she said
she shouldn't have eaten so she would do
better
tomorrow yeah so then i grabbed
another video of hers i spent hours
researching and re-recording a response
and then that one got taken down again
not surprising considering it had like a
few hundred calories
and included meals like a carb blocking
protein bar
and a dessert of a sugar-free monster
drink
blended with some ice to make some kind
of virtually calorie-free
slushy yeah it was a lot
now despite the annoyance that this has
been i
am thrilled that tick tock actually
deleted the entire channel
i mean i'm just so happy that tick tock
has finally started to take a stand
against some of these problematic pieces
of content
but alas she started a new channel with
a few new what i eat in a day
so i thought we would take a look at one
example
so i guess i started with a monster i
don't remember what i ate this day and
then i had the rest of my inari for
dinner
then i had sushi again i had spring
rolls and seaweed chip
then i went to the movies so i got these
little snacks at home it was such
vibes vegan pie from pi faith some chips
some other little snacks um why did i
have nutella
so let's start with the monster drink
this one has about the same amount of
caffeine as coffee about 150 milligrams
per can
but it's important to note that energy
drinks have been the subject of
countless public health campaigns there
are over 20 000 trips to the emergency
room in the united states
every year alone just from energy drink
use
the biggest risk however is in younger
kids
people with heart or anxiety issues and
folks who
mix energy drinks with alcohol it's also
worth saying that a lot of energy drinks
are regulated as
supplements and supplements are
notoriously
poorly regulated so personally and
professionally
they're just not something that i
recommend as for the rest of her day
it seems like this young woman has
essentially
swung in the opposite direction with her
approach to eating and food
while her old channel was full of what i
ate in a days that
rarely cracked a thousand calories and
featured
big salads of virtually just vegetables
25 calorie corn cakes fat burners and
calorie free desserts
her meals now are almost exclusively
restaurant food fried food and sweets
rather than me taking the time to
painstakingly make gentle suggestions
for
how to make these meals more balanced i
think i will just say
that a healthy diet is a moderate diet
and it's not surprising to me to see
such a record of
extreme restriction to be followed up by
fries pies chocolate and ice cream all
of which are fine and healthy in
moderation
but probably don't feel so good in
excess
day after day now i'm not diagnosing
anything here but i do just want to
remind you that
disordered eating content can look like
a variety of different things so
it's just interesting to me that tick
tock flagged
and removed the old wedding day content
and now this tick tocker has pivoted to
this
which is deemed okay and it probably
seems okay in isolation but
when you look at the overall picture you
might start to see some problematic
cracks
it's like youtube's mukbang trend which
is something i would also
love to see erased so i do hope that
this young woman is able to find peace
with food
as she continues on her eating journey
and i look forward to
ai or algorithms being able to pick up
on those subtleties
to be able to protect vulnerable viewers
all right
back to the video let's move on to
exhibit b
[Music]
okay so this video kicks off with a
weigh-in as this video specifically
calls out that
this is what she eats to lose six pounds
in a week
she then starts not with breakfast but
with a lunch meal
of some grilled potatoes and roast
chicken so
i've talked about intermittent fasting
before here on my channel
but my bottom line here is that if this
is a way of eating that feels good to
you
great not everybody likes to eat
breakfast or
to snack but just know that when it
comes specifically to weight loss
the evidence suggests that it's no more
successful than
continuous caloric restriction so if
you're a breakfast person
like i am this may not
work well for you as for the nutrition
in her first meal of the day
i am happy to see some complex carbs and
protein
but i would definitely love to see a
little colorful veg in here for some
extra micronutrients
and some fiber especially if weight loss
is her goal next is a snack of
annie's fruit snacks which i know are
often touted as a healthier alternative
to gummies
because they are organic vegan and
gluten free
and the package says right there that
they're made with real fruit juice
and there's nothing wrong with them at
all but if you look at the ingredients
you'll note that the first ingredients
are not actually fruit or fruit juice
they're syrups and cane sugar organic
fruit juice
doesn't even come in until the fourth
ingredient and
ingredients are listed in order of their
quantity by weight
so i wouldn't count on these for a
serving of fruits and veggies in your
day
if she just likes them great of course
enjoy the gummies
but i would say pair it with a piece of
whole fruit or
veggies for some more fiber benefits
now moving on we got dinner which was
two slices of avocado toast
so finally we got a little healthy fats
and a little bit more carbs going on
but again since weight loss is
apparently the goal here
and we know that protein is king in the
satiety hierarchy
i would love to see a good quality
source of protein
here so that could be as simple as some
grilled tofu
some canned salmon on top or a few eggs
or she could even use my hack and puree
in some white beans
with her avocado spread it also wouldn't
be a bad idea to like throw some more
veggies into the mix which
again will help to boost satiety and
meal volume
which can help support weight loss
efforts finally we've got some cookies
and low calorie ice cream to finish the
day
now i've got no qualms with cookies or
low calorie ice cream if you like them
and i absolutely think that all foods
fit even in the context of wanting to
lose weight
but we also don't want to crowd out
other important nutrients in the day
so because there isn't a whole lot of
actual foods in this diet in this day
and therefore we're low in a wide range
of micronutrients
a lot of which we're not going to get
from cookies or ice cream
i would encourage this tick tocker to
maybe
add some fruits to her ice cream or some
like nut butter with her cookies
to help bump up the nutrition in her day
again
to me it is all about adding not taking
fun foods
away and speaking of adding i would say
that we need to do
a lot more of that even if we were to
estimate that this girl's
maintenance caloric needs are around
2000 calories
this diet is probably giving her around
a 5500 caloric deficit for
the whole week and if weight loss was as
simple as a perfect mathematical
equation
and side note it's not that would result
in about a
1.5 pound of fat loss per week
so if this video states she's losing 6
pounds per week
where's the other 4 and a half pounds
coming from
yeah she's coming from muscle and water
not the fat that you actually apparently
would want to lose
[Music]
next week eggs and spinach broccoli
three cooked shrimp protein bar
tuna salad wow okay
well lots to unpack here
so breakfast we've got two eggs with
some sauteed spinach which
i think we could classify as a good
start
um i probably want to throw in like a
few more random veggies in there
and more importantly make sure that i
was getting in some fiber
and carbs with some whole grain toast
for example
but that snack just some plain
frozen broccoli no i mean
i love my veggies too but my followers
know
that when we talk about solid snacks we
talk about
hcc that is my hunger
crushing combo so broccoli on its own
does have a little bit of fiber but to
turn it into a satiating snack
we'd want to pair it with some protein
or fat
so maybe like a drizzle of tahini or a
little hummus for dipping
or stir fry with a little bit of tofu or
eggs
but we gotta talk about this lunch
because
this one makes me feel a little
uncomfortable
we got three itty-bitty
shrimp three shrimp that can't be more
than like
20 calories that is not even an
appetizer in my books
i'm hungry now shrimp are naturally high
in protein and pretty low in fat
so yes they're a great option for those
looking to lose weight
but this is not a lunch my six-month-old
baby
polishes off three shrimp as a snack and
he's literally
16 pounds soaking wet so we could throw
those
shrimp with a few more of course in a
bowl with some like rice and veggies
maybe some
cashews or pop them into a couple
tortillas for a quick taco lunch
to make an actual meal but i gotta say
that a big old plate with just three
tiny little shrimp on it
that is triggering even for me next
we've got a protein bar for snack which
again good snack but because we haven't
seen
any carbs yet and very few calories
i would definitely pair that bar with
some fruit
toast or maybe some oatmeal and finally
we finish
off the day with a tuna salad now i love
tuna as an inexpensive convenient
source of protein and i'm always down
for a big ass
salad as a meal but in the context of
this day
this is not enough we could totally add
like some pita bread or a couple slices
of whole grain toast
to turn it into a handheld dinner or add
some cooked whole grains to that bowl
to just bulk it up but basically bottom
line folks
this is not enough food this caloric
intake is not only super unsustainable
and dangerous
but it may actually be counter-intuitive
for long-term weight loss
you'll probably lose some fast weight
early on especially if it's just like
water and some muscle mass
but we have so many metabolic
adaptations that occur
to bring our weight back up to where it
wants to be
and in the end that often can land us at
an even
higher weight than where we started when
we're taking on these
extreme extreme diets the result is that
the next time that the dieter goes to
try to lose
that weight they need to eat even fewer
calories to even make a dent
i'm sure all of these young people on
tick tock
don't realize that they may be setting
themselves up for a legitimate
lifetime of severe under eating and
fighting with their weight what's even
more alarming to me
than the diet itself is that this user's
profile
states that she's healing from binge
eating disorder
and that the diet was based on her
doctor's suggestion
i'm sorry what why the [ __ ] would he say
that
i am so exhausted with the number of dms
and emails that i get from people
struggling with disordered eating who
have been clearly
misled by their health care team this is
such
lazy irresponsible information and in
the case of this person and her eating
disorder
it may not only not be helpful but it
actually may be
really dangerous advice my instinct
tells me that her doctor
like a lot of society is seeing a girl
who's gained weight from binge eating
and is prescribing extreme weight loss
as the solution to that specific
problem classic fat phobia and weight
bias
but this doctor may not understand that
the weight gain is
actually a symptom of the problem
and extreme dieting is actually what
causes it or makes it worse
as i discussed in my glow up diaries
review right here
one of the primary causes of binge
eating
is restriction hard stop so if you want
to stop binge eating and help your body
return to its natural set point weight
dieting to lose weight fast is the last
thing
you should be doing i am shocked and
disgusted that
any health care professional would
recommend a diet like this to anyone
never mind somebody in eating disorder
recovery ah
as if i am so mad
anyways i need to go take a snack break
to like cool off after this one
but i think my point with this is quite
clear
stop watching tick tock weight loss
themed
what i eat in a days honestly this
platform has so much toxic diet culture
content
it makes me cringe every time that i
launch the app
so if you want to see some more moderate
balanced weight loss information
i compiled some more useful tick tock
tips in my video
right here but until then thank you
again to buildbar for sponsoring this
video if you liked it be sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
on other tik tok content that you want
me to review
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye and for more great videos like
this check out the link right here
you